Do you trust your gut?
Imagine you've been saving up money for a while,
so you visit the bank ready to make your first major investment.
You talk with an advisor, and after a few minutes,
they tell you about a plan that you feel is extremely risky.
You ask them why,
and they just say they have a good feeling about it.
Would you feel safe?
Of course not.
Which is why we use data strategies.
This is simply an understanding of our personal objectives,
collecting data and then managing
and analyzing it to ensure that it aligns with these objectives.
Gone are the days of simply trusting your gut.
Today, businesses work with data analysts,
engineers and scientists to form these data strategies
leading to better outcomes.
So by understanding them, you can position yourself for success
and make a meaningful contribution to the world of data and analytics,
even in your personal life.
To learn more about all things data,
head on over to the Data Differentiator,
IBM's Guide for Data Leaders and enthusiasts alike.
We hope to see you there.